Estamos viendo un informe detallado que aborda la selección del tratamiento farmacológico
inicial y escalonado en adultos con artritis psoriasica periferica activa.
Este documento responde a la pregunta de ¿Qué farmaco se debes coger primero? ¿Cuáles
quedan para pasos siguientes? ¿Y qué criterios aplican entre eficacia, seguridad, conveniencia
y costo? En pacientes adultos con afectación articular periferica y factores de mal pronóstico,
aunque el Gusel Cumab tiene la mejor evidencia de eficacia para la artritis y la psoriasiscutania,
el tratamiento inicial recomendado por la guía es el Metotrexato. Pese a hacer el farmaco
con eficacia más débil en la tabla, su conveniencia es superior debido a que se administra
por vía oral y su costo es bajo al ser un genérico. Además, la guía conseja agotar al
menos un ses de mar antes de escalar a tratamientos biológicos. Y dentro de estos, el Metotrexato
es el preferido cuando hay afectación cutania clínica relevante. Para el segundo escalón,
las alternativas dependen de manifestaciones no articulares que acompañan la enfermedad.
El Gusel Cumab y otros inhibidores de interlausina 23 son elegidos cuando la piel tiene peso
clínico, pues demuestran alta eficacia y un perfil de seguridad favorable, aunque su costo
es elevado. Por otro lado, los anticuerpos monocronales anti-TNF son recomendados especialmente
cuando co-existen la uvitis o la enfermedad inflamatoria intestinal. Estos biológicos
tienen eficacia similar para la articulación, buena conveniencia para comorbiridades específicas
y cuentan con versiones biosimilares que reduce en su costo. Los inhibidores de Jack
pese a mostrar eficacia superior, quedan reservados para el momento después del fracaso
de al menos un biológico, o cuando este no es apropiado, por advertencias de seguridad
emitidas por la FDA y la agencia europea. Estos medicamentos orales también tienen un costo
alto y son considerados una opción cuando no se pueden usar biológicos. Finalmente,
la llen fatiza que la elección no recae solo en la eficacia articular, sino en una
secuencia de tratamiento donde la conveniencia y el manejo de manifestaciones extraarticulares
como afectación cutania, uvitis o enfermedad intestinal, determinan la decisión en el segundo
escalón. La guía no dispone de datos comparativos sólidos sobre seguridad entre los CSDDRD y los biológicos
o entre los distintos biológicos y excluye escenarios con enfermedad axial en tecitis predominante
o formas leves del artritis. Este informe ofrece un marco claro para seleccionar tratamientos
en función de la actividad local y sistémica del artritis psoriasica periferica, equilibrando
eficacia, seguridad, conveniencia y costos en un enfoque escalonado.
Conveniencia y costo para establecer un abordaje escalonado, me gusta que la aproximación
es muy clínica, nada de abstractos. Exacto y hablando de la población que cubre
el informe, se concentra en adultos con artritis psoriasica periferica activa, incluyendo
desde poliartritis, hasta monoartritis y olivartritis con factores de mal pronóstico. Pero
ojo, excluye por completo la enfermedad axial predominante, la entesitis y también la enfermedad
leves infactores de mal pronóstico ni afectación cutania significativa.
Sí, y eso me parece clave para entender el alcance del informe. Porque la guía recalca
que la artritis psoriasica no es una sola entidad, sino un conjunto heterogéneo.
El grado de actividad debe valorarse según la manifestación predominante, articulaciones,
piel, entesitis, dactilitis o enfermedad axial. O sea, toma en cuenta la complejidad clínica
real y sobre todo deja claro que la elección del tratamiento en el segundo escalón no
la define solo la articularidad, sino lo que la acompaña clínicamente. Eso me parece
súper importante porque no obliga a pensar la enfermedad en conjunto más que en compartimientos
estancos. Y para ayudarnos a entender esa elección, el informe estructura del juicio con base
en cuatro ejes muy claros, eficacia, seguridad, conveniencia y costo. Pero siempre comparando
entre los candidatos, nunca por separado.
Sí, me parece que ese marco comparativo es lo que le da rigor. Por ejemplo, en eficacia
miran las respuestas clínicas con escala reconocidas como ACR-20 para la articulación
y PASI-90 para la piel. Pero en seguridad que suele ser un tema clave, aquí la guía no
la usa para determinar el escalón inicial o el segundo, salvo para relegar a los inhibidores
de Jack por las advertencias regulatorias.
Claro. Y eso habrá un debate sobre cómo la seguridad se integra en la práctica. El informe
reconoce la falta de datos comparados entre ses de mar y biológicos, o entre los grupos
de biológicos, dejando un hueco importante.
La guía prefiere ordenar por eficacia y manifestación acompañante, no por toxicidad
comparada, lo que tiene implicaciones para la toma de decisiones.
Y hablando de escalones, el primer paso es el métodrexato. ¿Qué es interesante? Porque
siendo el medicamento con base de eficacia más débil, según el informe, es el seleccionado
como tratamiento inicial.
Sí. Y ahí está el punto curioso que me gusta destacar. Pese a su eficacia inferior
y eso incluye menor efecto en la piel comparado con agentes dirigidos ahí, el 23 y el 17.
Sigue siendo el primer paso porque la guía insisten agotar al menos un CSD-Mart antes
de escalar.
Y además, tiene ventajas prácticas que pesan mucho. Es oral, se puede administrar en domicilio,
tiene flexibilidad para intentos adicionales antes de pasar a un biológico y su costo
es claramente inferior. Estamos hablando de un genérico barato frente a biológicos
de marca con precios mucho más altos.
Eso habla de un balance pragmático entre eficacia y otros aspectos. En la práctica clínica,
no siempre es el fármaco con mejores datos el que usamos primero, sino el que mejor
encaja en la secuencia más segura y costo efectiva.
Totalmente.
Ahora pasando al segundo escalón, el informe analiza principalmente tres candidatos.
Gusel Cumab, anticuerpos monoclonales anti-TNF e inhibidores de Jack.
Gusel Cumab aparece como el candidato con la mejor evidencia de eficacia, con un número
necesario tratar de solo cuatro para respuesta articular y dos para aclaramiento cutanio
a las 24 semanas.
Además, superfil de seguridad es positivo según la guía, basada en datos robustos
y experiencia con inhibidores relacionados.
Pero claro, tiene la desventaja de la conveniencia. Es para entrar lo que limita la comodidad
y su costo es alto, sin vios similares homologados, lo que afecta su accesibilidad.
Por otro lado, los anticuerpos anti-TNF muestran eficacia equivalente entre biológicos
para la articulación, pero son la única opción con evidencia directa en UBEITIS, que es
una comorbilidad determinante en la elección.
Además, su conveniencia es alta en esos pacientes con UBEITIS, un enfermedad inflamatoria
intestinal porque resuelven ambas manifestaciones, una gran ventaja terapéutica.
En vios similares que reducen su costo comparado con otros biológicos de marca.
Lo que ubica a los anti-TNF como alternativa preferida cuando hay UBEITIS y opción válida
en enfermedad inflamatoria intestinal.
Me gusta como la guía refleja que el eje que decide el segundo escalón es la cobertura
de comorbilidades, no solamente la efectividad articular pura.
Y luego los inhibidores de Jack, que presentan eficacia superior en articulación, pero menor
en piel comparado con IL-23, IL-17 y su seguridad es claramente inferior con albertencias
regulatorias mundiales.
Por eso quedan reservados para después del fallo a un biológico o cuando no es posible
usar uno.
Sí, y aunque son farmacosorales con buena conveniencia, compartiendo el rango alto de costo, la precaución
de la FDA y la EMA, es un recordatorio claro de que la guía no solo mire eficacia, sino
también riesgo a largo plazo.
¿Y qué te parece enfoque de priorizar manifestaciones acompañantes para seleccionar biológicos
en lugar de solo ir por el que tenga mejor eficacia articular?
Me parece acertado porque refleja la realidad clínica.
La artritisoriásica no es solo articulación, por ejemplo, para afectación cutania significativa,
se privilegen inhibidores de IL-23 o IL-17.
Y en enfermedad inflamatoria intestinal, anti-TNF, inhibidores de IL-23 o Jack.
Eso convierte la guía en más que un árbol lineal.
Es una especie de mapa que adapta la estrategia según el cuadro clínico global.
La elección se vuelve multidimensional.
Sí, y otro punto que me parece muy valioso es que el informe reconoce sus limitaciones.
No cubre enfermedad axial ni entesitis predominantes, ni tampoco la enfermedad leve sin factores
de mal pronóstico, que tienen recomendaciones separadas.
Eso evita malinterpretarlo o aplicarlo fuera de contexto.
Cosa que a veces en clínica pasa y puede llevar a decisiones erróneas.
Para cerrar, creo que la conclusión clave es que Metotrexato sigue siendo el initial treatment
recomendado, pese a la menor eficacia directa, porque la guía prioriza un enfoque escalonado
que equilibre eficacia, seguridad, conveniencia y costo.
Adaptando la elección del biológico, según las manifestaciones acompañantes.
Y los inhibidores de Jack, aunque prometedores en eficacia, quedan bajo reserva por seguridad.
Lo que muestra la importancia de evidencias robustas y advertencias regulatorias en la toma de decisiones.
Así que la guía propone una estrategia pragmática
que concibe el manejo desde una multifactorialidad real,
integrando comorbilidades y costos,
y señalando vacíos en seguridad comparada como áreas para futuras investigaciones.
No te parece que eso configura un enfoque muy sólido para un manejo personalizado,
que está lejos de la simplificación de el mejor fármaco, es el que hay que usar siempre.
Totalmente, y creo que eso es una lección importante para todos nosotros en la práctica clínica
y en diseño de terapias.
Bueno, pues yo creo que nos quedó un buen panorama de este informe.
Muy útil para quienes deciden estrategias terapéuticas complejas.
Sí, espero que la audiencia pueda sacar provecho de este análisis
para abordar de manera informada y crítica a la artritis oríásica periférica activa.
Perfecto, gracias por la charla.
Gracias a ti, nos vemos en la próxima.
Hola, ¿qué tal?
Hoy vamos a hablar de un tema súper interesante.
La artritis oríásica periférica activa
y cómo se decide su tratamiento inicial y el siguiente paso si el primero no funcione.
Claro, o sea, la artritis oríásica no es solo inflamación de las articulaciones, ¿verdad?
También puede afectar la piel y otros tejidos.
Y en este caso, nos enfocamos en la que afecta principalmente las articulaciones periféricas activas en adultos.
Exacto. Y la guía que revisamos responde a una pregunta clave.
¿Qué medicamento elegir primero?
¿Cuál queda para después?
¿Y por qué?
Aunque hay medicamentos con mejor eficacia.
El primer paso es metotrexato.
Ahí está lo curioso, ¿no?
Porque el metotrexato es un fármacoclásico, oral y bastante barato.
Pese a que suficacia es más modesta, comparada con los medicamentos biológicos más nuevos.
Sí, y es que funciona como ese primer escalón,
un poco como cuando está subiendo una escalera,
empiezas por la opción más sencilla y económica,
que además puedes tomar en casa.
Y solo si no funciona pasa algo más compleja.
Y si metotrexato no es suficiente,
entonces vienen los biológicos,
que son medicamentos diseñados para actuar específicamente en el sistema inmune.
Pero aquí la elección no depende solo de cuánto duelen las articulaciones,
sino de qué otras partes del cuerpo estén afectadas.
Ah, por ejemplo, si la piel está muy afectada por psoriasis,
se prefiero un inhibidor de IL-23, como Gusel Cumab,
que es super efectivo para la piel y también ayuda con las articulaciones.
En cambio, si hay inflamación en los ojos,
lo que se llama UBEITIS,
el medicamento preferido es un anticuerpo monoclonal anti-TNF,
porque es el único con eficacia comprobada en esa manifestación.
Y si además coexiste una enfermedad inflamatoria intestinal,
se pueden contemplar anti-TNF,
inhibidores de IL-23 o incluso inhibidores de Jack.
Justo, pero ojo con los inhibidores de Jack,
que aunque son efectivos para la articulación,
tienen advertencias serias de seguridad por parte de autoridades mundiales.
Por eso se reservan para cuando ya fallaron los biológicos o no son adecuados.
Exactamente lo más curioso es que el fármaco con la mejor evidencia de eficacia,
Gusel Cumab, no es el primero que se usa,
sino que se inicia con metotraxato por su conveniencia, costo,
y porque así lo recomienda el tratamiento escalonado.
Sí, y esto subraya que el tratamiento se adapta a cada persona según qué manifestaciones tenga,
tratando no solo las articulaciones,
sino también la piel, los ojos y el intestino,
para un manejo integral.
Pues entonces en resumen empezamos con metotraxato, barato y sencillo.
Si no es suficiente, se lige el biológico según qué síntomas acompañen.
Los inhibidores de Jack se guardan para los casos donde los demás no funcionan o no son opción.
O sea que es un modelo pensado para ser eficiente y seguro,
siempre adaptado a la persona.
Eso me parece clave para entender la complejidad de esta enfermedad.
Sin duda.
Bueno, gracias por acompañarnos hoy.
Esperamos que esta guía te haya aclarado
cómo se lige el tratamiento en esta forma de artritis.
Nos escuchamos en el próximo episodio.